everyone hates to have a significant
portion of their income taken by the
federal government every single paycheck
while it is a nuisance we also know that
this is necessary in order to foster
development and fund essential
government programs but is that actually
true does a federal government need to
charge income tax in order to run well
while the Democrats are pushing for
higher income taxes to provide things
like universal health care and tuition
free college there are several countries
out there that do not charge any income
tax at all from not go to the Bahamas to
the UAE but these countries aren't on
the brink of bankruptcy it is actually
quite the opposite as they're doing
really well from to government-owned
airline giant's st had an Emirates -
Bugatti and Lamborghini police it seems
like the UAE is doing quite well indeed
so what are the u.s. decide to ditch
federal income tax today considering
that income tax takes up such a large
portion of her income it makes sense
that income tax revenue accounts for
just a little over half the total US
federal tax revenue so if income tax was
cut out the US would instantly lose out
on 1.74 six trillion dollars in revenue
taking that into account how to many
quickly survive without this major
source of income well usually the
answers natural resources tourism or
some other government funded program
that funds money into a federal
government in the UAE this makes it
possible for residents to not only not
pay income tax but also not pay sales
tax instead the government gets revenue
through hefty fines and royalties on oil
and gas the UAE has one of the most
expensive fine system in the world and
tax on oil and gas companies range from
55 to 85 percent of Koel operating
profits on top of this the government
makes a lot of money off of tourism as
many of the popular tourist destinations
is government-owned not to mention there
is a government service fee meant to
stay at hotels and restaurants and that
the government owns two multi-billion
dollar airlines
so that's how the UAE is able to keep
their government running but we don't
even have to look that far there are
several states within the US that don't
have state income tax like Texas and
Alaska these states like the UAE make
money through one of those other venues
even the u.s. itself didn't permanently
impose federal income tax until 1913
before that while there was income tax
here and there for funding things at the
Civil War
it was until a 60 amendment that a
permanent income tax came to be since
that time the US has racked up a lot of
expenditures that would not be possible
without this revenue one solution to his
funding problem is that the government
could increase sales tax and considering
that people have more money to spend in
travel sales tax revenue along with
revenue from government-owned cruise
destinations like the Grand Canyon the
Statue of Liberty would increase but
this would not nearly be enough to cover
the deficit as a result the US
government would no doubt have to cut
out government funded programs since the
lost revenue is instead going to
residents of the United States the most
meaningful place to cut funding will be
welfare programs like Medicare and
Social Security with people now have
that money the cutting of Medicare would
make a much tougher for people to get
affordable health insurance and this
would lead to many people not taking
health insurance costing hospitals
millions of dollars as for Social
Security
this would not nearly be as impactful as
Medicare as people would simply be
expected to save for their own
retirement which is definitely
reasonable plus many people often
contribute more money Social Security
than what they receive anyways so these
people would actually benefit from this
so theoretically this shouldn't really
be an issue but in reality Wayne take
into account Americans abysmal saving
statistics you belie that this would
quickly become major problem people
would simply have much less money going
into retirement which would further
discourage people from taking health
insurance on top of this we would
probably also see less unemployment
benefits and possibly stricter
regulations on obtaining student loans
in essence each individual would have a
lot more responsibility people can't
just go on and spend all this extra
income that they are getting they would
have to save strategically for
retirement and ensure that they have
emergency funds for getting through
unemployment or starting medical
emergencies they would have to make sure
to save more money for the children's
college and may be more inclined to take
better care of their health
while this X responsibilities may be a
problem for many as they would simply
waste more money as they get more money
this doesn't have to be a bad thing for
people who have a good grip on their
spending habits is to open up a whole
new slew of possibilities for instance
they may now be able to max out their
401k or Roth IRA every single year now
and if they have more money left over
they
could delve into investments they don't
have to be super savvy and make insane
tech investments or build up a real
estate empire they can simply lay back
and buy government bonds or municipal
bonds to support a community while
earning better interest in banks the
possibilities are truly endless for
people who use it well but what about
the economy
what cutting out income taxes help the
economy now this is quite complicated as
initially the US GDP would tank
decreasing by trillions of dollars as
government spending will plummet just as
a recap GDP the sum of consumer spending
investments thorin spending and net
exports so as government spending
decreases the u.s. GDP would directly
decrease but it doesn't just stop there
think about all the jobs that would be
cut from the 80,000 people working at
the IRS to thousands more working at
Medicare and other welfare programs
these people would nightly be spending
more nor investing more money as it
would have to find new jobs so this
would indirectly also decreased that GDP
but despite this as time progresses
people would ease into spending more and
more of their income whether they blows
more and consumer products or wisely
invested by the way the u.s. GDP would
increase as each person would contribute
more to GDP this would be accelerated by
the fact that price of goods would
decrease as businesses will have to pay
corporate income tax and as people are
spending more money there'll be more
opportunities to open businesses and
sell more products at consumers as these
businesses expand they'll not only
increase competition but hire more
people through an operation from
software developers to executives plus
already big businesses would be able to
sell even more products and as a result
they will hire more people as well soon
enough all the people displaced by the
government would be absorbed into the
private industry and they probably
making more money as well and within a
decade after abolition of federal income
tax the US GDP would rebound to its
original position
in fact the economists predict that the
GDP per capita may actually be higher
than it started GDP per capita is not
always the best way to measure how well
a country is doing but a higher GDP per
capita generally means better terms of
living along with lower unemployment
rates and then there's politics and
abolishment of income tax must
supported by a significant majority of
the population for such a radical change
to be passed by Congress as a result
this means that either a Democratic
Party has died out or to have complete
change of political agenda in order to
have a chance at winning an election we
will see political parties shifted focus
onto economics like what early America
were there was a Federalists and the
Democratic Republicans which were based
on the support for the federal bank this
could be a Democrats or a small a
capitalist party but either way the
government would be run by people with
conservative beliefs while the economy
speech in all there will be negative
repercussions eventually as time moves
on more and more people spend more and
invest and save less of course there
will always be people who spend their
money wisely these people will be doing
better than ever before I have more
freedom than ever before as well and yes
the rich would be getting richer and the
poor would be getting poorer but it's
not really witches fault as everybody
would have more opportunities it's just
that only some choose to handle their
money well or follow their dreams
getting a decent paying job would be
quite a noble and starting a business
realistically cannot get easier or more
profitable than this
the problem is that the general
population will neither put in the work
to grow a bustling business go manage
your extra income well and eventually
this will lead to major issues people
will start retiring later and later or
die working Esther didn't save enough
money to retire this will make it harder
for fresh college graduates to get a job
and much more difficult for people to
get promoted as these experienced
workers will cling on to her jobs as for
people who do end up retiring most will
have to downgrade their lifestyle
possibly something even worse than
living out of Social Security checks
this will lead to a decrease in general
public happiness as it has been proven
by all the Scandinavian countries that
more welfare programs is correlated with
more happiness mounting public
distressed will eventually cause
protests and rebellions and we will see
a president win an election based on the
premise of promoting welfare and how do
you fund these programs once again
income tax we would find ourselves right
back to where we started actually
further back than where we started as it
is evident cutting federal income tax
would simply not be sustainable for the
u.s. unless the lost revenues filled in
by a supplemental revenue source maybe
the US could build true attractions like
the Burj Khalifa or palm islands that
attract people from all over the
and bring in more revenue but without
more revenue in other sectors the
federal government cannot cut income
taxes as that would note I've been to
lead to public outrage over all this
would be the closer to a pure capital
society that we can get to without
cutting out basic government regulation
while this can work in a small country
filled with enthusiastic capitalists or
concrete that can be sustained out for
other means at the UAE for country as
bacon traverses the u.s. a pure capital
society just like a pure social society
just will work and we will need a mix of
both socialism and capitalism to keep
the general population happy or at least
generally not unhappy now I don't think
we need take it as far as democratic
socialists want to take it from a
federal job guaranteed to Medicare for
all personally I think we already have a
good mix but that's just what I think
what do you guys think would you be
interested in an income tax free society
or do you already know that you'll blow
all of your money and so you'd rather
have the government take care of certain
things make sure to comment that down
below also if you guys like this video
they mix up a like and consider
subscribing like to see more videos just
like this one but until then I'm hari
and I'll see you guys on the next one